[Musique]
des images dans le métro de kiev de gens
qui se réfugient dans le métro de
plusieurs villes d'ukraine parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de géopolitique on parle
de deux grandes manoeuvres russe faut
pas oublier qu'il ya déjà qui depuis la
nuit dernière ont entendu des bombes ils
doivent aller se réfugier en écoute ici
le monde
pas perdre de vue les gens sur le
terrain les citoyens stéphanie chouinard
révèle jacques michel surgit bonsoir
bonsoir stéphanie je commence avec vous
oui on en parle depuis trois semaines
malgré tout quand ça arrive c'est le
choc la stupeur quand même
oui on le savait à peu près depuis lundi
avec le fameux discours de monsieur
poutine qui était assez sans équivoque
qu'ils ont sur cette façon de voir
l'ukraine et son manque de
reconnaissance totale de la souveraineté
ukrainienne mais là on voit que depuis
hier on on voit les uns et pas qu'on
voit les bombes et les impacts non
seulement sur la frontière mais aussi
sur les civils comme on l'entendait tout
de suite on se demande qu'est ce que les
sanctions auront un effet ce que comment
l'europe comment le washington on peut
se demander aussi qu'elle est la porte
de sortie ultime pour vladimir poutine
rafa jacobs absolument ni à quel point
l'ouest l'occident les états unis
particulièrement peuvent peut-être
facilité cette porte de sortie là parce
qu'il faisait très franchement la
tragédie convoi à laquelle on assiste
depuis les dernières heures à quelque
chose de profondément inquiétant dans la
mesure où justement il y en a pas de
porte de sortie claire lentement et les
états unis semblent je pense qu'il faut
le dire très clairement le largement
impuissant avait quelque chose de
honnêtement que je trouve profondément
émouvant dans disco joe biden cet après
midi lorsqu'on parlait de la défense des
idéaux démocratiques s'était senti en
même temps dès qu'on a commencé à
interroger président américain sur ce
qu'il allait réellement faire on l'a vu
souvent ignorée des questions il y aller
de façon disons assez hésitante les
américains sont largement coincé est
rappelons le toujours hyper clairement
et aucunement question président les
encore sans équivoque cet après-midi
aucunement question d'envoyer les
sud-américains que ce soit maintenant
dans un jour où dans une semaine dans un
mois sur le terrain en y créant donc
présentement ce qu'on a ce sont des
sanctions les sanctions qui adapte un
hulot s'il faut être très clair un effet
de dissuasion est sensé un nul sur le
président jean michel suau g
voie de sortie est ce qu'on peut où il
est trop tôt on en voit poser dans le
brouillard
on est vraiment dans le brouillard
d'autant que la méthode qui a été choisi
par les pays occidentaux pour faire
pression sur la russie c'est des
sanctions hors des sélections ça peut
peut-être marché est un peu tendre la
main et ça peut peut-être marcher mais
ça prend du temps et
les sanctions de toute façon sont
gratuits alors par exemple si on veut
utiliser
l'interdiction de toutes transactions
bancaires avec la russie enfin passé le
premier jour on fait ça un peu plus tard
etc alors donc pour l'instant ça n'a pas
d'effet dissuasion sur monsieur poutine
qui de toute façon les voyez venir
savait à quoi s'attendre et d'autre part
pour publier que ces sanctions doivent
avoir des effets sur nous
probablement des prix de l'énergie plus
élevés
déjà cette difficulté comme ça avec
l'inflation et avec les plus de défense
aux états unis aref rosacée section là
il se fait mal et lui même ne faut pas
l'oublier alors un moment donné c'est
pas le père est le plus solide
je resterai raffinage mondial social
shenzhen parce que ses clés joe biden à
trois problèmes principaux depuis des
mois l'inflation l'inflation et
l'inflation est là présentement il n'a
aucune bonne option pour confronter
cette situation là dans la mesure où
présumant con qu'on observe sa constance
à dire une hausse encore plus marquée
des prix de l'énergie aux états unis
dans un contexte actuel de déficit
budgétaire historique à washington la
seule chose que la maison blanche en
vraiment considéré comme proposition
comme option ce serait de mettre une
pause sur les taxes sur l'essence sauf
que puisque un énorme déficit à seule
façon de faire ça c'est quoi mais c'est
de faire en sorte que la réserve
fédérale aux états unis impriment de
l'argent qui fait quoi qui contribuent à
l'inflation donc comme à la fois james à
qui la porte parole de la maison blanche
hier le dit il présida le récent
essentiellement aussi dit aujourd'hui
il va effectivement comme michel
également le mentionnait avoir un coût
la grosse question c'est de savoir si un
président qui un taux d'approbation
autour des 40 % dont le taux
d'approbation sur la gestion de la crise
ukrainienne et sous la barre des 40%
hall capitale politique nécessaire pour
que sa population accepte de porter ce
genre de couleurs je reviens ses fans du
chouinard je reviens à vladimir poutine
quels sont selon vous les prochaines
étapes pluzz et bleu est ce que s'il
arrive a installé un gouvernement pro
russe à kiev où on a parle moins dans un
arnal mieux oublier les u la crimée il
ya eu la georgie où on est devant
quelque chose d'un blocage qu'on
n'arrive pas à voir comment on va
apaiser les choses
voilà vous demandez sortir la boule de
cristal est un exercice assez périlleux
mais bon ce qu'on voit actuellement
c'est contente d'aller chercher et de
toucher les gens qui sont créé de petits
éventuellement ce qu'on pourrait faire
aussi c'est d'imposer des sanctions à
monsieur poutine lui même ça c'est un
endroit où on n'est pas allé non la part
des alliés du canada est-ce que ça ça
pourrait faire en sorte qu'on n'arrive
pas à ce scénario là où on n'a pas
seulement les deux régions de l'est de
l'ukraine qui sont contrôlées par des
rebelles pro russe mais où justement qui
est veuve la capitale elle même est
tombée on espère ne pas investir je vais
me reposer je commence avec vous ses
fans et mes tours de table pour poser la
question différemment monsieur macron
boris johnson monsieur trudeau ont tous
dit et d'autres aujourd'hui du g5 ont
tous dit c'est la menace la plus
sérieuse depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale êtes vous d'accord c'est
fini
j'ai l'impression que le parallèle est
pas tout à fait exact on est
certainement dans une situation où en
europe effectivement on se rapproche de
la situation qu'on avait à la fin des
années 30 avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais on en est pas rendu à un
scénario où on aurait une guerre
mondiale on souhaite certainement pas
n'arrivait à
à cette situation là et on essaie de
contenir évidemment la crise à la région
on a faim on a un mot patrice oui
autant de risques la réponse est oui
comme stéphanie en a mentionné est ce
qu'on est les deux pieds dedans et le
maintenon mais ce qu'on est dans une
situation où il ya un risque de conflit
qui déborderait potentiellement très
largement comme on en a pas vu depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale en
europe personnellement je persiste à
croire que la réponse malheureusement et
oui on le souhaite pas mais si oui ou
non c'est pas un pronostic mais c'est à
une place michel
il ya toujours un danger que ça dérape
il ya toujours un danger que ça
septembre mais c'est vrai à quoi j'ai
passé quand j'ai vu ça ce matin j'ai
pensé à l'invasion de la tchécoslovaquie
heavy rain combat
équipé pour se retenir contre les virus
mais il y avait un côté c'est ma zone d
influence et dans ma zone d'influencé
qui va y avoir des gouvernements que je
peux c'est ça que monsieur poutine
stationnement est en train de faire est
en train de faire une opération de
changement de gouvernement qu'elle
n'aime pas le gouvernement qui est la
ville veut littéralement un pays
satellites comme dans le bon vieux temps
sauf que à cause de ça justement les
autres pays ont jamais seront jamais
sont jamais intervenus ta question de
tchécoslovaquie ou dans la zone
d'influencé russe alors parce qu'on lui
accordait conduire corps des années pas
qu'on lui accordait oui là on lui
accorde - oui mais
il ya beaucoup de jeu à les voir en
france combien de policiers qui disent
pour comprendre la position de la russie
surtout à droite les politiques et il se
met quand même beaucoup de jamal débat
public qui disait il faut comprendre la
position des russie à leur porte devenez
membre alors c'est pas sûr que c'est pas
unanimes disons à l'occident de dire
bon sanctions tour de table rapide
est-ce que ce qu'on a adopté au canada à
washington est ce que ça fait quand même
une différence et fanny
certain que si canada fait cavalier seul
il ya très peu d'impact sur les
décisions qu'on prend il faut toujours
que ce soit de façon concertée on a vu
aujourd'hui au g7
certaines discussions sérieuses
justement pour aller de l'avant avec un
retrait de la réussite du programme
swift boris johnson pour six très forts
de ce côté-là semblerait qu'à la table
du g7 monsieur trudeau aussi voulu
assouplir la position de monsieur
johnson même si c'est parce qu'on entend
de la part des médias canadiens je
trouve étrange mais ce serait
certainement l'une des options suivantes
suite à ce qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui
je rappelle souffle c'est le la
messagerie entre les grandes banques de
la planète mais banques dans le monde
exactement si on enlève saut à la russie
là ça va très très mal
conclusion 45 secondes raphaël michel
raffin si je laissais le times celle en
ce qui me concerne j'avais tout
simplement ceci si ça fonctionnait ont
leur ai déjà vu ok oui chelsea sanctions
vos pneus rhône on ne peut pas rien
annoncer non plus michel
on pouvait pas de programme mais les
sanctions je le répète ça marche des
fois et ça marche lentement alors c'est
pas quelque chose au dos mercredi
prochain on va dire at il ya d'autres
centres aux marchés c'est à très
longtemps
quelle journée quand même merci beaucoup
à vous trois merci bonne soirée on se
reparle
pour moi pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh